[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti oggi sono qui per
raccontarvi quello a cui tengo di più
ovvero l'empatia legate alla sicurezza
informatica
se ci pensate empatia e sicurezza
informatica apparentemente sono due
parole molto lontani da quando c'è
empatia nelle persone che svolgono
questo lavoro e da quando c'è empatia in
quelle che sono poi le minacce che
andiamo ad affrontare oggi è che stiamo
affrontando tutti insieme oggi ogni
giorno facciamo una premessa
quando parliamo di sicurezza informatica
le persone che al che ci lavorano
all'interno sono generalmente
considerate persone senza distinzione
anche buoni anche cattivi che vedremo
oggi sono considerate persone che
apparentemente sono poco socievoli
apparentemente sono persone un po strane
che fanno dei tratti caratteristici dei
loro tratti psicologici sociali quella
che forse anche il cavallo di forza il
loro cavallo di battaglia quindi persone
che pensano un po out of the box fuori
dagli schemi per svolgere al meglio la
propria passione per portare avanti
quello che amano fare abbiamo lo
sterotipo dell'hacker
adesso sto portando avanti un qualche
film in queste slide forse qualcuna vi
anche più familiare questa sicuramente
la slide che tutti quando mi dicono ah
ma tu conosci degli hacker e hanno
sempre matrix in mente come quella scena
quindi uno schermo nero con del codice
verde
questo ancora oggi è la figura
dell'hacker una persona che sta tutto il
giorno davanti allo schermo nero a
digitale del codice volte anche
apparentemente casuale e poi ci vedono
così la sera finito di programmare siamo
vestiti così andiamo fuori a fare le
nostre cose e vestiti in questo modo ora
questa è un'altra
una maschera di guy fawkes guy fawkes fu
una persona che se vogliamo solamente
nel c il 5 novembre del 1605
in quanto membro della congiura delle
polveri decise decide di provare a far
saltare la la camera dei lord a londa
quindi da allora negli ultimi anni
soprattutto molti degli attacchi
informatici che vediamo anno la maschera
di guy fawkes che avete visto babilmente
anche in v per vendetta e film hanno
questa figura del rivoluzionario del
ribelle della persona che si nasconde
dietro la maschera di un qualcuno che a
detta sua e non sarò io qui a giudicare
fece un qualcosa di molto rilevante
un'azione molto rilevante ora come vi
dicevo i tratti con cui ci troviamo a
discutere quando parliamo di sicurezza
informatica vedono nella crea anche una
figura dalla psiche quindi a livello
psicologico molto fragile molto diversa
da quella che è la realtà tra virgolette
a cui siamo abituati
e ancora oggi è molto difficile
avvicinarsi ai a chi gli appassionati di
informatica perché vengono visti come
quelle persone che pensano fuori
dall'ordinario come vi dicevo e che
tuttavia ci tengono a mantenerlo riserbo
la loro privacy quindi a non esporsi
troppo col mondo circostante con moni in
cui vivono
ma isolarsi nel cosiddetto scanzi nello
scantinato con i propri simili a
programmare ecco questo è uno degli
stereotipi non sbagliato ma che
sicuramente ha tante faccetta tour e che
oggi vi mostrerò che cos'è la sicurezza
informatica negli ultimi anni
vediamo sempre più spesso parlare anche
sui giornali finalmente mi viene da dire
di credenziali trafugate carte di
credito violate o clonate siti web che
sono stati compromessi e le informazioni
di clienti presenti all'interno di
questi siti web venduti da
malintenzionati
i cosiddetti oggi mi sentirete parlare
molto di attori malevoli
dopo vi spiegherò che cosa sono
sotto il mio punto di vista che cosa
sono gli attori malevoli e quando
parliamo in sicurezza informatica va
fatto un appunto molto importante
non esiste il software sicuro chiunque
provi a vendere qualsiasi marchio
qualsiasi persona o fuori
vittoria bene un software figura dovete
sapere che stanno intendo un software
può essere sicuro a un dato momento
hicks quindi oggi un software
apparentemente sicuro è vero ma il tutto
può cambiare velocemente
domani successivamente a una verifica
fatta da esperti di sicurezza o da
appassionati del settore che si sono
messi a testare eventuali vulnerabilità
a cercare vulnerabilità all'interno di
questo software
capirete che un software che a oggi
avete sentito qualche giorno ha fatto
dalle menti di whatsapp whatsapp era a
detta di tutti inviolabile
l'inviolabilità di un software dipende
sempre e va in contrapposizione poi con
quello che è meglio va di pari passo con
quello che è l'investimento che un
attore malevole mette nel trovare
vulnerabilità
voi pensate che ci sono anche che
trovano buone abilità per gioco ci sono
anche che vengano retribuiti per trovare
vulnerabilità retribuiti in maniera
legale o anche in maniera illegale
quindi ci sono soggetti che finanziano
questo tipo di ricerca atto a la vendita
successiva della conoscenza quindi il
potenziare la potenziale vendita di vita
da sfruttare contro altri target e ci
sono poi anche invece etici che trovano
vulnerabilità per il solo gusto di
mettersi alla prova di trovare
vulnerabilità di lavorare con chi ha
creato questo software mettere in
sicurezza
quindi da un lato abbiamo gli hacker
etici io una cosa a cui tengo tantissimo
e appunto fare la distinzione tra
criminale il normale criminale sia esso
in forse informatico meno che tra il
profitto arrecando dai danni o arrecando
se vogliamo disagi ad aziende a persone
e la che retico il cui scopo appunto e
di mettere in sicurezza questo mondo
oggigiorno l'economia che si è creata
attorno alle
abilità fa sì anche che tantissimi
ricercatori vengano retribuiti dalle
aziende per trovare vulnerabilità e
retribuiti dalle aziende per mettere al
sicuro il mondo clima che attori
malevoli possano sfruttare questa
vulnerabilità
ora come mettiamo assicura il mondo è un
lavoro di squadra
pensate semplicemente a quando
aggiornate il vostro telefonino quindi
avete un iphone android qualsiasi altro
marchio e premete aggiorna telefono il
telefono fino a via avete applicato gli
aggiornamenti
avete fatto la vostra buona azione per
oggi ovvero mettere in sicurezza
voi stessi e chi vi sta anche intorno
attraverso semplicemente un click
di pari passo l'azienda deve mettere
deve lavorare sulla propria ricerca
sulla pa da sicurezza al fine di mettere
in sicurezza tutto quello che è l'eco
sistema software i cui di cui di cui
controlla ora dovete immaginare la
sicurezza informatica come e questa
ricerca delle vulnerabilità come una
casa al cui interno viene salvata una
porta blindata
ora probabilmente installazione della
parte blindata fa sì che un lato dotato
di 2 mar dello non riesca ad entrare ma
pensate se al posto di un ladro dotato
di un grimaldello quindi probabilmente
avete filtrato via il 70 per cento di
ladruncoli qualunque tuttavia c'è ancora
un 30 per cento un 20 per cento che è
dotato di strumenti sofisticati o che
semplicemente trovar modo di entrare
dalla finestra la stessa cosa avviene
per la sicurezza
la sicurezza è fatta di tanti componenti
le aziende sono fatti di tanti
componenti software hardware anche solo
casa vostra e fatta di tanti componenti
con le connesse internet con il cervello
quindi cosiddetti smart choice nel caso
dei giocatori smart objects quindi
pensiamo a fa un po ridere la cosa ma la
vostra macchina non cervello con essa
internet spesso le macchine più recenti
oppure
il frigorifero anche il frigorifero
ricevere gli aggiornamenti la
televisione quindi stiamo andando in un
mondo sempre sempre più iperconnesso e
stiamo andando verso un mondo dove nei
prossimi anni vedremo un'esplosione di
dare un cuore da un cervello e mette
online in qualsiasi dispositivo
progettato spesso progettato non per
fini online ma che poi finisce online
per necessità di mercato quindi non con
la sicurezza non creato con la sicurezza
tenendo in mente la sicurezza nello
sviluppo ma che una volta adesso diciamo
in e con l'economia di massa quindi
installato comunque nel mondo qualcuno
si chiede a e adesso come faccio a
mettere in sicurezza
tornando al tema dell'empatia ci tengo
molto a dirvi che la sicurezza
elettronica è sicuramente un tunnel
tecnologico ma non solo è secondo me
frutto di collaborazione tra le persone
che ne fanno parte e alex tra mons il
capo della l ex capo della sicurezza di
facebook e nel 2016 ha provato a
studiarci io faccio parte di quelli che
sani technology di questa industria e ci
ha studiato dicendovi voi siete bravi e
tutto ci mette vi mettete l'impegno ma
non pensate alle persone
pensate unicamente alla palla agli
aspetti tecnologici del problema non
pensate a rendere la vita delle persone
più semplice
applicando i vostri filtra i controlli
siamo migliori e detta vostra in termini
di siti e in uscita mettervi nei panni
delle persone che utilizzano la
tecnologia ogni giorno quindi la
tecnologia non è intuitiva la tecnologia
è difficile e tutti le migliorie che ha
portate a livello di sicurezza rendono
la vita delle persone più complessa
invece che facilitarla e questo ha
creato un grosso dibattito e delle anche
grosse polemiche attorno a questo tema
tuttavia la sicurezza è fatta di tanti
componenti e il componente umano nella
sicurezza come vedremo nelle prossime
slide è essenziale perché tutti noi oggi
siamo bombardati di mail queste sono
solo due esempi di email dove vengono
fatte delle campagne di estorsione atte
a estorcere denaro principalmente
mettendo di paura ovvero una di queste
era appunto ti sto guardando da alcuni
mesi o tutti i tuoi dati nel coi dati
del tuo computer accesso al tuo computer
posso vedere quello che fai e per
renderla quasi vera o meglio reali reale
anche una persona ci può cascare vengono
utilizzate delle informazioni che
vengono capite o attraverso i social
network o attraverso quelli che poi dopo
vedremo sono le violazioni all'interno
dei siti web e il successivo furto di
dati
perché questi attori ma nei voli usano i
vostri dati per girarvi la minaccia
quindi abbiamo i nostri dati invece di
usarli bio i contattiamo permettervi
ancora più paura perché dandolo ip
dettagli sulle stesse sulla vostra vita
voi direte allora questa persona fa sul
serio
stiamo attenti se possiamo mandare un
video dalla regia
volevo far vedere anche perché la
sicurezza non lavora di squadra buona
cry nel maggio il 12 maggio del 2017
wanaka ifo un attacco quindi un worm una
persona sviluppò un gruppo di persone
sviluppo questo questo virus
se vogliamo che andava a sfruttare una
versione vecchissima di un sistema
operativo windows
nello specifico e che per colpa delle
persone se vogliamo che non hanno
aggiornato semplicemente torniamo al
tema degli aggiornamenti l'aggiornamento
vi mette in sicurezza da una cosa tanto
semplice quanto ancora la grande sfida
ha già nei propri sistemi aggiornare i
propri ambienti produttivi
ecco l'assenza di queste pratiche di
buona igiene e di sicurezza se vogliamo
così si definisce nel gergo fece sì che
in un giorno solo questo è il terzo
giorno già arrivammo a quasi 500 mila
infezioni in tutto il mondo
queste infezioni appunto colpirono per
primi gli ospedali uk e poi si
propagarono su tutta internet
internet è uno strumento molto potente
quanto subiamo interconnessa appunto
come dice la stessa parola tutte le
tutti le aziende sono interconnesse fra
loro tutte internet stesse esposto a
tante persone a tanti attori male
non è quindi è un ambiente molto fragile
ancora oggi una fata di castello di
carta che basta una piccola miccia per
far esplodere
quindi questa fu la mappa delle
infezioni come vedete nessuno fu
risparmiato buona parte del mondo fu
infettato e a livello economico
riprendersi da questa da questa
problematica quindi da questi che furono
i problemi creati da wanaka i cc si
misero mesi la produzione di molte
aziende fu sospesa e voi sapete meglio
di me quanto la produzione
pensate alla produzione di una filiera
industriale sospendere la produzione di
una figlia industriale comporta milioni
di euro potenzialmente al giorno persi
in attesa di installare tutti i vostri
sistemi e installare tutta la vostra
infrastruttura e questo perché fu
sfruttato una vulnerabilità di un
qualcosa risolto
sei anni prima quindi per sei anni le
persone hanno ignorato perché tanto non
c'e la consapevolezza del rischio una
delle grosse di grossi problemi delle
grosse sfide che abbiamo è la consap
essere consapevoli dei rischi che
corriamo ora deve venire dall'alto
io sempre più spesso purtroppo quindi in
controtendenza con quello che dovrebbe
essere sento
e avverto la mancanza di consapevolezza
dei rischi cyber quindi di quelle che
sono le problematiche legate
all'informatica la sicurezza informatica
alle sfide agli attacchi informatici da
parte del top management se vogliamo
quindi da dirigenti amministratori delle
aziende e ci sono questi cinque punti
che ho riportato oggi nella slide che ci
tengo a leggere con voi allora il primo
è no ma questo attacco informatico che
stiamo subendo non mi riguarda riguarda
lo stagista o riguarda al marketing
quindi la l'ambiente dirigenziale si
sente sempre escluso da quello che può
essere l'attacco informatico quando
invece esattamente l'opposto e l'attore
malevolo quindi un attaccante vuole
carpire informazioni dalle persone che
ne hanno di più vuole estrarre queste
informazioni quindi fa compie un furto
d'identità o di dati dalle persone che
hanno accesso ai più dati possibili
quindi sono esattamente
persone che vengono attaccate possibile
oppure vedere il tema della
cybersecurity come un tema di haiti
quindi di information technology del
dipartimento di informatica
anche questo è assolutamente falso la
sicurezza informatica ci riguarda tutti
ogni computer connesso alla rete
aziendale o anche alla rete di casa
vostra e potenza con potenziale target
quindi non si tratta dello programmatore
dell'esperto di sicurezza o del
responsabile tecnico ma si tratta di
tutte le persone
quindi è un lavoro di squadra che
riguarda tutti un'altra delle grosse
sfide e fa capire che gli attacchi
provengono anche dall'interno
parliamo di spionaggio industriale
parliamo appunto di diciamo marco lanza
dei propri sistemi quindi mancati
aggiornamenti sui propri dispositivi
personali collegati avete aziendali che
fanno sì che appunto l'azienda venga
compromessa attraverso quello che è un
cellulare a uso personale di una persona
o un portatile di una persona pensare
che il cloud che va di moda oggi giorno
quindi sempre più aziende si stanno
affidando al cloud ovvero mettere i
propri sistemi i propri dati presso
qualcun altro quindi non avere più in
casa da gestire sistemi e applicazioni
[Musica]
nulla di tutto ciò metti su internet e
da lì accedere mutamente a questi dati
per certi versi si è fatto bene può
essere molto più sicuro della vostra
infrastruttura magari gestite nello
scantinato aperto senza misure di
sicurezza tuttavia va specificato che
non è che il cloud è la plancia ottimali
è un lavoro di squadra anche di è un
cosiddetto lavoro a dire responsabilità
condivisa
dovete lavorare col cloud drive affinché
appunto tutto questo sia possibile
l'assenza di empatia fa sì che creiamo
prodotti che nessuno usa quindi che non
tengono in considerazione l'utente che
sono tutto
benché usabili semplici funzionari e che
semplificano la vostra vita
quindi la grossa sfida che abbiamo come
tecnologia appunto è quella di lavorare
il più possibile insieme affinché questi
programmi questi software vengano
diciamo utilizzati
non riusciamo a capire come i nostri
avversari ragionino lavorino se non ci
mettiamo nella testa di un possibile
attaccante non è scemo mai non ci pare
le sommosse clienti impiegati a genere
controlli più livelli di sicurezza senza
senso aggiunge rete all'interno dei
vostri processi più le persone si
diventa diventeranno creative nel
bypassati quindi essere coinvolgenti
quando facciamo sicurezza all'interno di
un contesto dobbiamo farlo per gli altri
non per noi
se no il cosiddetto non essendo empatici
non mostrando empatia non attireremo
assoluta non avevamo alcun supporto da
parte delle aziende
queste sono le fari tradizionali se ci
pensate
chi di voi non ha ricevuto soldi da un
principe in africa lontano chi di voi
non ha ricevuto biglietti aerei o
voucher gratuiti di netflix o qualsiasi
tipologia di siamo bombardati ogni
giorno di e mail e mail di servizi che a
volte usiamo a volte no ci sono tante
campagne di phishing che vendono
protagoniste persone che hanno dato a
una banca hicks i propri dati
non essendo nemmeno clienti di quella
banca ma si sono sentiti diciamo si sono
affidati di questa e mail di questa
banca che gli ha scritto e questa banca
ogni settimana chiedeva un cambio
anagrafico la nuova password
il nuovo username e mese si sono fidate
perché la media della legittima il logo
carino il tasto sembrava scritto bene e
comunque è arrivata quindi dovevo
assolutamente essere sicuro che fosse
quella mail quindi chi di voi ha mai
vinto un viaggio ad esempio un biglietto
aereo rispondendo a una di queste mail
compilandolo di questi moduli credo
nessuno in questa stanza
l'attacco ovviamente il vettore ancora
oggi più comune è la mail le persone
ricevono mail che possono contenere al
sentano link da cliccare pagine che si
aprono dall'apparenza realistica diciamo
oppure dagli allegati allegati i
malevoli con cui fate doppio clic
vi chiedete continua a cliccare su
questo file ma non succede nulla e avete
appena dato
tutto diciamo l'accesso al vostro
computer a un attore malevole questa
persona da quel momento tramite il
vostro click responsabile se vogliamo ha
accesso a tutti quelli che sono i vostri
dati può vedere in tempo reale quel le
cose che digitate le notizie ai due
giorni fa di una gang europea arrestata
che associato circa 41.000 conti in
banca per un totale di 100 milioni di
dollari
in questo modo facevano installare un
qualcosa alle persone tramite campagne
di mail le persone facevano doppio clic
e poi intercettavano semplicemente
quando le persone si autentica vano
della propria banca magari per mandare i
soldi al figlio a volte non serve
neanche tutta questa complessità di
studiare la campagna di phishing trovare
una persona perché i social network ci
hanno aiutato molto in questo hanno
aiutato le persone malevoli in questo
quegli attori malevoli pensate a
instagram con ester specifico boarding
pass carte d'imbarco
voi avete a disposizione un 125 126 mila
carte di imbarco delle persone che
stanno vicino a voi o anche lontano
voi mi direte ok ma una carta di imbarco
chi se ne frega una carta d'imbarco e
abbastanza per autenticarsi nel sistema
della vostra compagnia aerea ristampa il
biglietto e usare in quel biglietto per
accedere ad aree riservate
dell'aeroporto e potenzialmente fare
qualcosa che potete immaginare o anche
semplicemente rubare le miglia o se la
carta d'imbarco
se il vostro profilo all'interno del
vostro sito contiene a carte di credito
prenotare altri biglietti carte di
credito
io non pensavo fosse possibile asi
social network le persone pubblicano le
proprie carte di credito e voi mi direte
va beh sì ma tante il davanti della
carta c'è quel codice ci puoi fare poco
perché non è il codice supersegreto
quindi persone ci vengono incontro è
solitamente mettono c'è un telethon
perché avete più bello anche oppure
commentano ancora perché questo è un
bellissimo su twitter dove tante persone
hanno cominciato a chiedere alla persona
si ma vogliamo vedere anche se il codice
di che assomiglia vicino alla tua
personalità e lei tutta gasata ha
risposto con questo codice
ovviamente queste carte qua vanno
bloccate subito
perché possono essere utilizzate per
molti pagamenti online non è neanche
necessario il codice dietro la password
vado velocissimo password del grosso
problema di questi tempi le password
ancora oggi voi direte nel 2019 le
password sono superate le password sono
ancora il miglior mezzo per prendere
possesso dell'identità digitale di una
persona le passo e vengono gestite in
mano modo da tanti di noi forse anch'io
ma soprattutto l'assenza di
consapevolezza del problema
quanti di voi in ufficio hanno colleghi
o anche a casa che salvano le password o
su un file di testa sul desktop oppure
numeri pieni di post it o su post it
sullo schermo ad esempio ancora questa
azienda secondo me li batte tutti perché
un foglio all'ingresso dell'azienda chi
diceva dite chi siete
dite la vostra password attuale e che
passerete dalla settimana prossima e
quindi le persone hanno cominciato a
scrivere tutte tutte le password e qui
vado molto veloce ma le passo di giorno
sono sempre quelle tutti usano un 2 3 4
5 6 tutti usano le solite combinazioni
quindi ci piace avere le combinazioni
sott'occhio quindi dalla q all'api come
vedete sono le combinazioni più
utilizzate siamo un po pigri consentiamo
le password e noi technology come
rispondiamo complicando le regole per
settaggi della password cambiare la
password ogni settimana con su un piede
solo inserendo due caratteri maiuscoli e
minuscoli non replicando le passa
precedenti questo è sicuramente la
risposta perché riceviamo e queste come
le persone rispondono a quella politica
restrittiva che noi abbiamo appena messo
uno è carattere più utilizzato dopo la
passò il precedente
quindi le persone cambiano la passo ma
mettono l'uno finale col punto
esclamativo
quindi cosa fare per chiudere che siamo
né tantissimo le cose sono molto
semplici questo è un invito quando
andate a casa ogni singolo servizi deve
avere una sola password
quindi è necessario che quella password
se univoca così che se quel dato sito
venga compromesso voi non ve veniate
esposti completamente
quindi la vostra violazione si limita
questo web quindi abbiate passo di
univoche per ogni servizio utilizzato un
secondo livello di autenticazione la
banca già adesso di mandare sms o via
dato un token fisico utilizzate anche
per tanti servizi che lo mettono a
disposizione password manager sono
quelle applicazioni che vi possono
aiutare per gestire le password
applicare gli aggiornamenti sembra una
cosa scontata ma applicati gli
aggiornamenti al vostro frigorifero alla
vostra auto al vostro tostapane al
vostro baby monitor a qualsiasi
dispositivo che sa che è connessa a
internet è connessa a casa vostra
infine intestate le copie di dati che
fate non è sufficiente copiare su un
disco o su un flop perché poi tra cinque
anni di rete a ma come faccio a leggere
questa coppi che non ho più lettore di
floppy o ancora un cd si deteriora in
cinque anni quindi siate un po
consapevoli che non basta copiare i dati
ma vanno copiate vanno testate le copie
questo è un regalo andate su questo sito
e mettete la vostra mail poi diventa
alla fine di tutta questa discussione
regaliamo la nostra mail si vi potete
fidare non perché bellino logo ma perché
il servizio è legittimo e mettendo la
vostra mail vi si aprirà un mondo perché
capirete quanto la vostra e mail è
esposta su internet quindi quali sono i
siti che hanno la vostra email che hanno
subito una violazione e di capirete che
è quindi evidente se usate la stessa
password per tutti i servizi
basta una violazione per esporre
totalmente grazie mille dall'attenzione
[Applauso]